david we're getting close to those
georgia runoffs can joe biden
get anything done if democrats don't win
georgia
so this is a different version of
something we've we've been talking about
um if democrats are unable to win both
of those races
making the senate a 50-50 tie with
kamala harris as the tie-breaking vote
i would be shocked if anything
substantial is done from a legislative
standpoint mitch mcconnell will go back
to the obama playbook as i talked about
in the last segment
obstruct everything offer no
bipartisanship period
in addition to that um even
with winning the runoffs there are lots
of issues that are going to be a fight
uh when you consider i know the the it's
almost cliche to say but
uh joe manchin from west virginia is the
most right-wing
democratic senator there are lots of
biden ideas that i have a hard time
imagining
joe manchin goes for now maybe you can
find a republican or two
to go for them even if joe manchin
doesn't but the next two years will be a
very
big uphill battle for joe biden
legislatively
regardless of what happens in uh january
in georgia
without those wins nothing gets done no
and and joe biden will essentially have
to govern by
pyrrhic compromise where you have to
give up so much in order to get
republicans to
to work with you that if there's a
question as to whether it's even a
worthwhile exchange and by executive
order
fortunately biden can get a lot of
things done by executive order
and my hope is that what biden can't do
legislatively in these first two years
uh he can do via building goodwill and
and sort of reestablishing the us as
respectable globally
which our global reputation has been in
the toilet thanks to donald trump
um but but then you know the real the
complicated part the part where it gets
tough
is even with both senate seats
um what what of the big things
can you actually get done um
for some for really major things
you also need a super majority which
democrats with 50 50 and kamala
harris as the tiebreaker aren't aren't
going to have they'll be able to do the
budget bill that only needs 50 votes
they can put some extras in it and and
see what else they can get done that way
they will be able to confirm supreme
court justices if joe biden
indeed gets to nominate anybody and you
know maybe you can do some
infrastructure
uh maybe you can do it's just health
climate and tax reform seem really
really tough
um and uh it's it's going to be an
uphill battle so that's that's my
perspective at this point and then of
course there's this idea of
do they do they do away with the
filibuster um
divergent opinions on the left about
that let's just wait and see what
happens january 5th in georgia before we
have that conversation because i think
that
let's not even waste our breath on that
issue until we know
what's going to happen um in the state
of georgia
we have a great bonus show for you today
and remember we are off next week
no new shows next week everybody relax
the show's not canceled
just an end of the year break so bonus
show coming up right after this become a
member at joinpackman.com
to get instant access and then nothing
next week
and then back with you on monday january
4th 2021